after many years of getting basically
the same glassback design on the regular
iPhone models apple is finally switching
it up and giving us a new camera bump
redesign that I like to call the Cyclops
and in this video I'm going to explain
why apple is doing this and I'm also
going to share everything else that's
new with the new iPhone 16 and 16 Pro
leaks but back to the Cyclops design no
it's not like the Cyclops from Greek
mythology with a single huge eye but
more like the Cyclops from X-Men but
turned sideways like this but nearly not
as cyclopsychotride
[Music]
the iPhone 10 except that the flash will
be on the outside and of course will
have that squarish chunk of glass so
it'll look nicer overall now some of the
other prototypes also show a more basic
iPhone 11 design but honestly I think
that Apple needs to somehow mix things
up and I think the Cyclops design will
definitely make it stand out and show
that this is the brand new iPhone 16
which is very important for Apple but
now let me get into the real reason
Apple's going with the vertical camera
layout on the iPhone 16 because if you
didn't already know Apple intentionally
created a diagonal camera layout on the
current iPhone in order to allow enough
space for the crazy big camera sensor
with stabilization to fit so there's got
to be a great reason for the pivot back
to a vertical camera alignment right
well Apple actually has a pretty genius
master plan for a brand new special
feature but before I explain the new
quick video capture button I got to do a
quick shout out to our sponsor Rich this
is their tobacco brown leather wallet
which is insanely Compact and probably
the best gift you can get for a guy and
I've personally been loving their key
case which basically holds all of your
small Keys together like this so they're
not all sticking out all over the place
and being annoying so check out rid's
30% off holiday sale which ends tomorrow
by going to ridge.com maxtech with the
link below now getting back to that
special new feature that's going to be
enabled by the New Vertical camera
layout it's apparently the new 3D
spatial video recording that'll be
coming to the iPhone 16 and 16 plus
which is already available on the 15 Pro
Models by aligning the ultra wide and
Main camera vertically which are the two
cameras that are required for spatial
video and yes some people have already
viewed some of their own special video
on some headsets which is one of Apple's
biggest exclusive features which is
meant to revolutionize the way that we
take and view our videos and memories
now currently it does seem like a huge
gimmick to me but I honestly haven't
tried it yet and maybe it would blow my
mind so Apple's probably right about
this going into the future and that's
why they're intentionally aligning the
cameras on the new regular iPhone 16
models which will be limited to the
ultrawide and Main cameras to be able to
gather the 3D data to create the spatial
videos and one of the best ways to
upsell their Vision Pro headset is to
make sure that every iPhone can record
it which will be tempting for a lot of
people that end up trying it out at the
Apple Store and going even further there
is an even bigger feature that has
leaked for the entire iPhone 16 lineup
that'll push this feature even more and
that is apparently the brand new capture
button which would be located right
under the current location of the
millimeter wave antenna which will be
relocated to the left side of the phone
underneath the volume buttons this new
capture button will likely be capacitive
so it might not stick out like a regular
button but it'll still feel like a
button press due to Apple's haptic motor
vibration Mark Gman has just leaked that
this new capture button is literally
dedicated to taking videos with the idea
being that Apple really wants to make it
as easy as possible to record spatial
video making it more accessible with
this new button and based on the
location it's going to make using this
button the most natural in landscape
orientation so you're going to hold your
iPhone like this click the button to
instantly record spatial video which by
the way spatial video is not going to
work in in portrait orientation because
you need the cameras to capture 3D depth
data from the left and the right angles
up and down angles will not be able to
record this data accurately so take that
Tik Tock that's another win for
traditional YouTube widescreen format
but the really intriguing idea
surrounding all of this is the fact that
apple is so confident in the spal video
feature that they're literally going to
redesign the camera layout to be
vertical and add a dedicated capture
button just to push spatial video so
they're basically going all in so I'm
excited to see if they're actually going
to end up being right about all of this
but now let's move on to some other
iPhone 16 lineup leaks that we recently
got starting with the action button
apparently the iPhone 16 pro and pro Max
will be getting a larger action button
since the current one is quite small but
the reason they're probably doing this
is is because the regular iPhone 16
models are also getting the new action
button next year but it's going to be
the smaller version like we currently
have now in terms of the chips we have
some exciting news for the regular
iPhone 16 models with them rumored to be
getting a new a18 chip instead of just
reusing the previous pro model chip like
Apple has been doing so that's a big
deal because the current iPhone 15 is
still on 5 NM chip technology while the
Ros are chilling with the awesome new 3
nanometer Tech which is more efficient
so next year the regular iPhone 16s will
get 3 nanometer with the a18 while the
16 Pro Models will be getting the a18
pro which will basically be a beefed up
version with more RAM and more cores but
it's overall good news across the lineup
we also had a leak from the elec
claiming that the new iPhone 16s will
use updated micr lens OLED panels which
should actually be brighter while
increasing power efficiency which is
honestly going to help a lot to make
sure all of those display dimming issues
go away for good and it's going to help
battery life as well but to be honest
most of the exciting changes are rumor
to be coming to the Pro Models next year
for example the Pro Models will be
getting larger 6.3 and 6.9 in displays
which means that the smaller 16 Pro will
finally be getting the incredible 5x
telephoto camera that I've really been
enjoying on my 15 Pro Max on top of that
the Pro Models will be getting the new
5G modem chips that'll be more efficient
as well as the new Wi-Fi 7 spec that is
the first version that can connect to
multiple Wi-Fi bands at the same time
but unfortunately neither of those
features are coming to the regular 16
models and going even further the Pro
Models will be getting a much needed
upgrade to a 40 8 megap ultrawide camera
instead of the current 12 megapixel
version we've had ever since the iPhone
11 and we actually got the future road
map four camera upgrades as well with
apple planning to slowly transition all
of their cameras to 48 megapixels with
the ultra wide getting it next year and
the telephoto getting it the year after
that for a full set of three cameras
with 48 megapixel sensors across the
board so it's pretty clear that Apple's
plan is to slowly stretch out the
upgrades improving the iPhone a little
bit more one year at a time which sucks
for us but it makes sense for apple as a
brand but with that said let me know
your thoughts on the whole new Cyclops
iPhone 16 design and if it makes sense
for Apple to go with this down in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
this video you can subscribe above and
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one